France 24 et RFI présente
[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
au Parlement européen à Strasbourg pour
ici l'Europe nous allons faire un tour
d'horizon de cette semaine de
recomposition de la droite en Italie
suite au décès de Silvio Berlusconi mais
aussi dans le reste de l'Europe où elle
a remporté un certain nombre de scrutins
mes doigts clarifier son rapport avec
l'extrême droite nous en parlons
d'ailleurs avec le chef de fil des
républicains au Parlement européen
François-Xavier Bellamy bonjour rappelle
vous êtes ancien professeur de
philosophie député européen classé donc
dans le groupe du Parti populaire
européen dans cette émission qui vote
parfois avec le groupe réunion centriste
mais qui ne se prive pas de critiquer la
politique d'Emmanuel Macron alors vous
avez conduit
la règle dans ce Parlement qui a
beaucoup de sujets sur lesquels on
trouve des points d'accord avec tous les
groupes en tout cas il y a pas de il y a
pas de convergence particulière avec
avec Ryu ou d'accord de quelques natures
que ce soit je rappelle aussi que vous
avez pour noter spectateurs mené à la
liste LR en 2019 et obtenu 8,5% des
suffrages nous allons parler d'ailleurs
de votre positionnement dans la dans la
future campagne des élections
européennes mais si vous le voulez bien
on commence quand même par l'actualité
la plus frappante et toujours à la plus
terrible des opérations de
contre-offensive de l'armée ukrainienne
ont commencé comment vous voyez évoluer
ce conflit et la partition des Européens
dedans bien sûr il y a des sujets très
immédiats la question de savoir comment
nous allons faire en sorte de garantir
notre notre place dans ce défi
géopolitique global que la guerre en
Ukraine révèle le soutien
aux forces ukrainiennes obligent nos
pays à produire à produire en
particulier plus de munitions plus
d'équipements pour pouvoir combler aussi
les trous capacités de nos propres
forces armées mais un moyen et long
terme ce que nous voyons aujourd'hui de
façon très claire c'est que nous sommes
dans une situation de fragilité sur la
capacité de production énergétique en
Europe par exemple on l'a vécu avec
l'explosion des prix du gaz et
l'incertitude sur l'alimentation de
l'Europe en énergie en électricité au
cours du dernier hiver ce sera le cas à
nouveau l'hiver prochain aujourd'hui
l'Ukraine c'est évidemment une plaque
essentielle pour l'alimentation du
peuple ukrainien bien sûr mais aussi des
Européens d'une partie des pays
d'Afrique il y a eu longtemps la volonté
du président français Emmanuel Macron
développé une défense européenne
aujourd'hui on semble quand même se
ranger sous la bannière de l'OTAN en
tout cas pour organiser justement
l'aide à l'Ukraine pour l'immense
majorité des pays européens l'OTAN est
évidemment la clé absolue de leur
garantie de sécurité nous Français nous
avons souvent une position un peu un peu
différente un peu singulière en Europe
parce que avec notre armée nous croyons
assurer assumer seul les conditions de
notre de notre défense de fait malgré
l'engagement extraordinaire de nos de
nos forces armées malgré le fait que
nous ayons la chance de disposer d'une
armée qui en s'appuyant sur la diffusion
nucléaire mais aussi sur ses capacités
conventionnelles est capable
d'intervenir dans le monde entier pour
défendre les intérêts français il est
aussi absolument certain que nous ne
sommes pas capables de faire face à un
conflit de haute intensité par
nous-mêmes comme celui que les
Ukrainiens sont en train de vivre c'est
le chef d'état-major des armées lui-même
qui ne cesse d'alerter sur la nécessité
de nous préparer de nouveau à la haute
intensité mais tout cela se joue aussi
dans le cadre d'une alliance si nous
devons apprendre en Europe à être plus
autonome notamment sur le plan neutre
industrie de défense je ne crois pas un
instant pour autant qu'il y aura demain
une armée européenne parce que nous
avons des références trop différentes
pour cela parce que nous avons aussi des
choix géostratégiques qui sont eux-mêmes
divergents et c'est tout à fait normal
pour ma part je ne crois pas que
l'Europe soit une sorte de super-État
elle est une association de démocratie
qui souveraine s'engage pour défendre
ensemble leurs intérêts une échéance
électorale qui veut évidemment vous
intéresse au plus haut point les
élections européennes le 9 juin 2024
est-ce que vous êtes prêt à reprendre le
flambeau de la tête de liste des
républicains pour ce prochain scrutin
comme vous l'avez fait en 2019 est-ce
que vous vous avez des concurrents
d'ailleurs sur sur la ligne non pas de
concurrent d'abord ce qui compte pour
moi c'est je le dis depuis que ce débat
a commencé pour moi ce qui compte c'est
d'abord le fond le contenu de la ligne
que nous défendrons ce qui compte c'est
d'abord le collectif et je pense que ce
qui manque parfois la vie politique
française c'est justement le sens du
collectif Le Sens du bien commun nous
sommes là pour servir et nous sommes
chacun d'entre nous la uniquement pour
être utile à quelque chose qui nous
dépasse et en l'occurrence pour la
droite française mais aussi pour la
France et pour l'Europe cette élection
sera décisive et ce serait absolument
affligent de la ramener seulement à des
questions d'égo d'individualité de
parcours personnel les Français
attendent ce dont ils ont besoin pour
réduit par rapport aux années
précédentes c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire
8,5%
alors 8 élus au lieu de 20 que vous
aviez précédemment à quoi vous attribuez
finalement se relative revers est-ce que
il y a c'est lié aussi à vos
compositions conservatrices sur le
mariage pour tous ou l'IVG par exemple
ça c'est la caricature habituelle que
que qui est qui est en vogue chez ceux
qui veulent ne pas penser la réalité
c'est que quand on regarde les faits si
j'ai été investi comme tête de liste
dans cette élections européennes c'est
parce que notre famille politique était
déjà dans une situation très difficile
quand j'ai été choisi je le rappelle je
n'étais d'ailleurs même pas adhérent du
parti à l'époque les républicains
étaient donnés à 6% dans les sondages
donc effectivement nous avons traversé
nous traversons toujours aujourd'hui une
période de crise une crise politique
profonde c'est la crise des parties du
gouvernement en France le Parti
socialiste la connaît aussi et cette
crise elle a évidemment aujourd'hui
toujours un impact sur la réalité de
notre paysage politique puisque comme
vous l'aurez vu à l'élection
présidentielle nous n'avons toujours pas
réussi à relever la tête et à retrouver
la confiance des Français et la question
qui se pose pour nous aujourd'hui c'est
comment retrouver ce chemin de la
confiance et encore une fois je crois
que au-delà de toutes les caricatures
complètement absurdes ce qui compte
c'est revenir vers le fond dans cette
campagne européenne en 2019 nous avions
défendu je crois des projets des
propositions des mesures qui
correspondaient à ce dont l'Europe avait
besoin certaines d'ailleurs ont été au
cœur de nos débats européens je pense à
la taxe carbone à l'entrée du marché
unique c'était notre première
proposition de campagne sur la question
du nucléaire sur l'énergie c'est nous
qui avons mené cette bataille sur la
question de la protection aussi de notre
produit
clair il y avait une tendance très forte
de ce Parlement des institutions
européennes en général à combattre
l'énergie nucléaire aujourd'hui le
Parlement européen nous avons réussi à
construire une majorité pour soutenir la
filière nucléaire et et ça ce sont des
des batailles gagnées par des
amendements que j'ai eu l'occasion de
déposer que nous avons défendu avec
notre délégation sur les questions
d'agriculture sur les questions
migratoires là encore des batailles
importantes que nous avons menées
fondamental maintenant c'est de réussir
à venir devant les Français demain et
j'espère que les journalistes de notre
pays contribueront pour parler des
questions européennes on a aujourd'hui
un débat majeur au Parlement sur le
sujet d'un texte qui s'appelle
restauration de la nature dont l'impact
consisterait à remettre des terres en
friche à cesser d'entretenir des forêts
au nom de la restauration de la nature
faire baisser notre réduction
alimentaire et bien ces questions-là
elles sont décisives si nous nous
battons contre ce texte c'est parce que
nous avons besoin demain d'une majorité
au Parlement européen pour réussir à
faire en sorte que au nom de
l'environnement on n'arrête pas de
produire en Europe et qu'on ne décourage
pas tous ceux qui continuent et de créer
la semaine a aussi été marquée par
l'enterrement de Silvio Berlusconi un
homme de droite effectivement un
personnage incontournable et très
polarisant de la politique italienne
regardons tout de suite qui lui a rendu
hommage et dans quel ordre avec ce petit
récit
il a été l'un des premiers à réagir à la
mort de Silvio Berlusconi depuis Moscou
le président russe a rendu hommage à
l'ancien chef du gouvernement italien
mort à 86 ans
pour un politicien c'était un homme
extraordinaire il était très sincère et
ouvert et il avait un privilège que les
politiciens de cette ampleur n'ont pas
habituellement il osait dire ce qu'il
pensait
amis personnel de Vladimir Poutine
Silvio au Berlusconi a rejeté plusieurs
fois sur Kiev la responsabilité de la
guerre avec Moscou volody merzelanski ne
lui pas réagit à son décès à l'étranger
une poignée de dirigeants principalement
à droite de l'échiquier politique ont
rendu hommage aux cavalierets le Premier
ministre nationaliste hongrois salut un
grand combattant en France le patron des
républicains évoque un monument de la
politique en Italie Marine Le Pen parle
elle d'un personnage atypique richissime
homme d'affaires Mania des médias
président au club de football italien
celui qui a dirigé l'Italie pendant 9
ans a aussi été à plusieurs reprises
empêtrées dans des scandales sexuels et
poursuivi en justice à Strasbourg le
Parlement européen aussi a rendu hommage
à son ancien député
au nom du Parlement européen je veux
adresser nos condoléances à ses enfants
à ses collègues politiques à sa famille
et à ses proches dans ces temps
difficiles le gouvernement a décrété une
journée de deuil national
François-Xavier Bellamy voilà pour les
hommages il y en a un qui est
particulièrement embarrassant ces suites
Vladimir Poutine soyons soyons honnêtes
c'était d'ailleurs un sujet
d'embarrassement que l'échange de
cadeaux entre Silvio Berlusconi et
Vladimir Poutine pour le gouvernement
italien peut-être pour l'Europe
maintenant
mais là encore je le redis pour nous
enfin de fait si vieux Berlusconi
absolument incontestablement un moment
de la vie politique italienne c'est un
fait c'est un ancien député européen il
était normal de marquer le moment de son
décès ce qui est clair c'est que à la
lumière de ce qui se déroule aujourd'hui
nous devons tirer des leçons des
vulnérabilités de l'Europe on parle de
Silvio Berlusconi pardon de vous dire
aussi que par exemple l'ancien
chancelier socialiste Girard Schröder a
été l'un des grands organisateurs de la
dépendance de l'Union européenne au gaz
russe à travers la promotion des
énergies renouvelables à travers la
promotion des énergies éoliennes
solaires qui sont intermittentes à
travers aussi le lobbying anti-nucléaire
on en parlait à l'instant en fait en
faisant fermer les centrales nucléaires
en Allemagne les partis politiques
allemands de toute sensibilité on
structuré une relation de dépendance à
l'égard de la Russie et et regardez
aujourd'hui le parcours
vis-à-vis de la Russie on est d'accord
c'est très simple c'est que quand vous
mettez une éolienne à la place d'une
centrale nucléaire en réalité l'éolienne
elle produit mais une partie du temps
seulement elle a un facteur de charge de
20% environ 80% du temps restant il faut
compléter avec une énergie de
substitution et c'est un Égypte de
substitution de compléments et bien
c'est une énergie qu'on peut très
facilement allumer ou éteindre et ça
c'est généralement une centrale soit au
charbon enfin on n'en veut pas trop soit
une centrale à gaz et c'est la raison
pour laquelle évidemment ceux qui ont
fait avec le plus de détermination la
promotion des énergies renouvelables en
Europe c'était les acteurs gaziers qui
avaient un intérêt évident à ce que
l'outil nucléaire européen soit
fragilisé pour pouvoir exporter importer
du gaz vers l'Union européenne une
majorité d'hommages venait pour Silvio
Berlusconi de la droite et même de
l'extrême droite en Italie la Ligue et
Fratelli Talia sont en coalition avec
son parti donc
partie qui appartenait aussi aux partis
populaires qui appartient aussi forte à
Italia au Parti populaire européen comme
vous d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il contribuer
sylvie oberlusconi a des diabolisé
l'extrême droite dans un pays européen
très important
le fait était que en Italie les systèmes
de coalition et la structure même de la
vie politique et ça n'est pas
d'aujourd'hui que que Fratelli d'Italia
ou bien que la Liga font partie de
gouvernement de coalition à ceux qui
s'indignent de voir le PPE gouverner en
Italie avec ses deux formations
politiques on peut répondre que jusqu'à
il y a quelques mois c'est le parti
socialiste c'est le parti centriste
italien qui était tous les deux en
coalition avec la Liga de Matteo Salvini
qui aujourd'hui ici au Parlement
européen et dans le groupe ID le groupe
durablement national il faut je crois
sortir de ces de ces querelles
politiciennes de ces espèces de de
questions d'étiquettes qui en réalité
n'intéressera
au niveau du Parti populaire européen il
faut parler du contenu des politiques
quand il y a des divergences majeures
sur le contenu des politiques menées il
faut dire c'est divergences et il faut
les dire avec beaucoup de force quand
c'est nécessaire mais aujourd'hui encore
une fois le vrai sujet c'est qu'est-ce
que George jameloni fait dans la vie
politique italienne qui serait à ce
point scandaleux qu'il faille la
considérer comme devant être anathemisé
moi je suis très heureux vous partagez
le point de vue d'un mantra de Weber qui
est le patron ici du Parti populaire
européen qu'il faut faire alliance
postélection européenne précisément avec
le CR le parti de Georgia mélony est-ce
que tout le PPE est d'accord avec ça le
CR c'était le parti des conservateurs
britanniques ECF c'est le parti dans
lequel se trouve des formations
politiques qui gouvernent un peu partout
en Europe avec les droits et justice par
exemple le fait était que aujourd'hui le
sujet encore une fois c'est la question
du contenu des politiques que nous
allons essayer de mettre en oeuvre pour
les Européens
très conservatrice mais je suis pour que
nous travaillons avec des gens avec qui
nous avons tout à fait en commun sur des
questions qui intéressent directement
l'avenir de l'Europe si demain des gens
raisonnables chez Rignoux et je vois à
quel point le groupe Prino est en train
de se fracturer sur des questions comme
celle que nous évoquions à l'instant sur
la politique environnementale je vois
des élus de réunion qui sont en
coalition avec les Français d'Emmanuel
Macron et qui votent avec nous sur
beaucoup de textes nous avons évidemment
tout à fait ensemble aussi et puis il y
a évidemment des gens qui sont à la
droite de ce Parlement sur lesquels avec
lesquels nous devons pouvoir compter
c'est ce qui se passe d'ailleurs
évidemment dans les autres institutions
européennes regarder comment fonctionne
le Conseil la Commission au Conseil on a
vu madame Meloni aller en Tunisie tout
récemment avec Madame vanderleyen pour
travailler sur la politique migratoire
et la coopération migratoire moi je
crois que l'Europe c'est le fait de
parler avec les pays européens de parler
avec les forces politiques qui
représentent les citoyens des pays europ
forcément de cordon sanitaires avec
l'extrême droite il y aurait quelque
chose de profondément anti-démocratique
à considérer que certaines personnes ont
par principe une sorte de de tabou sur
la tête et qu'on a pas le droit de leur
parler et de travailler avec elle quand
il y a des désaccords de fond et vos
comptes et les accords de fond j'en ai
par ailleurs je n'aurais aucune espèce
de difficulté à l'assumer avec
aujourd'hui des groupes qui à l'extrême
gauche du Parlement européen défie aussi
l'état de droit ou bien avec des gens
qui comme Monsieur Timmermans sont
capables d'expliquer que ceux qui votent
contre sa loi sont contre la démocratie
il y a aussi des vrais problèmes dans la
santé du débat démocratique à aller
chercher peut-être dans dans tous les
groupes politiques en tous les cas c'est
inquiétude légitime elle doit s'exprimer
d'une manière qui soit cohérente sur le
chapitre migratoire qui est très cher à
votre cœur je crois il vous avait
considéré qu'il faut absolument
aujourd'hui que les demandes d'asile
soient effectuées à l'extérieur des
frontières de l'Union européenne ce qui
a été retoqué comme proposition dans
dans le pacte asile émigration qui vient
d'être adopté par les ministres
puisque c'est légitime de sous-traiter à
des pays tiers qui sont pas toujours
très démocratiques ni armés pour ce
travail justement de
séparer les migrants des réfugiés on ne
demande pas aux pays tiers de gérer à
notre place la politique migratoire des
pays européens mais ce que nous disons
de façon très claire et ça n'a pas été
retoqué puisque le sujet n'est pas
encore arrivé au Parlement donc on va en
discuter maintenant si vous sortez
d'Afghanistan parce que vous y êtes
persécuté vous ne généralement vous ne
rentrez pas directement de l'Afghanistan
dans un pays européen vous passez votre
route passe par des pays intermédiaires
qui sont des pays sûrs stables dans
lesquels il y a des représentations
européennes où vous devriez pouvoir
aller demander l'asile aujourd'hui le
grand drame c'est que pour demander
l'asile paradoxalement il faut avoir
réussi à mettre le pied illégalement sur
le sol européen c'est cela qui produit
les drames que nous connaissons en mer
Méditerranée il y a encore eu des morts
en Méditerranée si des gens sont
éligibles à l'asile pourquoi ne vont-ils
pas dans un consulat en Turquie pour
demander l'asile et on devrait fixer
cette règle simple que toute personne
ensuite qui rentre illégalement sur le
territoire européen sans avoir reçu
d'abord le message qu'il est éligible à
l'asile se verra interdire la
possibilité de formuler une demande
d'asile parce que aujourd'hui nous
donnons une prime à l'illégalité qui
occasionne ses morts en mer Méditerranée
et qui est d'une certaine manière la clé
du business des passeurs et du profil
qu'ils font sur la misère humaine merci
François-Xavier Bellamy on continue
d'ailleurs sur ce sujet du fameux pacte
migratoire et asile qui vient d'être
adopté au niveau des ministres avec ma
conso de Public Sénat c'est le débat
tout de suite sur France 24 République
[Musique]
merci de nous rejoindre depuis le
Parlement européen à Strasbourg surprise
récemment les États membres ont réussi à
trouver une majorité pour réformer la
politique migratoire de l'Union
européenne dans un contexte de hausse
des demandes d'asile en 2022 c'était 968
000 demandes qui ont été déposées plus
50% par rapport à l'année précédente et
depuis 10 ans les 27 étaient en
désaccord sur ce sujet sensible depuis
trois ans les négociations sur un
nouveau pacte asile et migration piétiné
et le 8 juin dernier bien les ministres
de l'Intérieur ont adopté un compromis
malgré l'opposition acharnée de la
Hongrie et de la Pologne et première
avancée de nouvelles obligations de
solidarité pour l'accueil des demandeurs
d'asile avec 30000 relocalisations
prévues chaque année pour soulager les
pays de première ligne Italie Grèce et
Espagne en tête ceux qui refuseront
d'accueillir les réfugiés et réfugiés
devront verser une compensation
financière à de 20000 euros par personne
par ailleurs il y a la volonté de
raccourcir les délais d'examens des
dossiers à 12 semaines pour se
considérer comme pouvant présenter une
menace pour la sécurité européenne ou
pour ceux qui ont peu de chance
d'obtenir l'asile en raison de leur
nationalité alors ce texte doit
désormais passer devant le Parlement et
ce avant les prochaines élections
européennes de juin 2024 et en attendant
la Commission européenne tente une
opération de séduction auprès de
certains pays de transit comme par
exemple la Tunisie afin qu'ils gardent
les migrants sur leur sol nous en
parlons aujourd'hui avec deux euros
députés l'un français donc Philippe
Olivier du groupe à la droite extrême de
l'hémicycle identité et démocratie vous
êtes plutôt favorable à une Europe plus
forteresse qu'elle n'est actuellement et
face à vous et bien en espagnol
socialiste Javier armoreno Sanchez
bonjour votre pays qui est sous forte
pression migratoire que pensez-vous
d'abord de cet accord trouver par les 27
que certains
historique a juste titre alors la
gestion des flux migratoires est un défi
européen auquel il faut apporter une
réponse européenne c'est vrai que ça
fait des années qu'on y travaille c'est
vrai que ça traîne mais quand un migrant
ou un demandeur d'asile arrive au
Canaries il arrive en Europe en tous
c'est 200000 personnes qui arrivent par
an sur 450 millions de problème c'est
qu'elles sont mal répartis donc c'est
vrai qu'ils arrivent plutôt comme vous
l'avez dit en Grèce en Espagne au
Portugal et donc il faut une et en
Italie oui pardon j'avais oublié
l'Italie et il faut deux principes de
base qui sont la solidarité et la
responsabilité et je pense qu'on a les
moyens en Europe d'accueillir ces gens
qui simplement recherchent une vie
meilleure donc cet accord va dans le bon
sens il va dans le bon sens c'est un
premier pas il faut le compléter parce
qu'il faut une approche holistique
notamment avec les canaux de migration
légale moi je suis le rapporte j'ai été
le rapporteur pour la carte la
Blue IV et le permis unique et je pense
qu'il faut aussi on parle on parle peu
c'est il fait ça fait partie du PACS
sans faire partie il est pas pris par
les médias comme dans le pacte mais on a
deux directives sur la table qui vont
faire avancer dans dans le sens de
l'immigration régulière dont on a besoin
et choisit alors le précédentes accords
c'était l'accord de Dublin en 2013 qui
avait pour principe de renvoyer toujours
au premier pays de la Rivier les
migrants ça ne fonctionnait pas parce
que c'était toujours les mêmes pays de
première ligne dont on a parlé on a en
quelque sorte trouver un moyen pour
partager le fardeau avec un objectif de
30000 relocalisations et demandeurs
d'asile par an vous dev vous devez dire
tant mieux non pas du tout parce que je
crois qu'il faut remettre ce pacte
immigration dans son contexte d'abord il
y a eu le pack de Marrakech en 2018 qui
est venu dire les hommes de la terre ont
droit à la migration c'était du droit
mou et là on passe à du droit dur c'est
à dire qu'on applique des mesures
coercitives pour rendre ce droit
tangible là en l'occurrence il s'agit
d'un basculement juridique de grande
ampleur on nous fait croire que c'est
une petite adaptation de texte qui
existe pas du tout c'est qu'on va
dessaisir les États membres de la
compétence migratoire c'est à dire que
avant ce sont les États qui décidaient
qui rentraient selon quelle modalité les
gens rentrez dans les pays et selon
quelle modalité il devait en sortir là
c'est l'Union européenne qui va
s'emparer de ça elle le fait toujours
avec le même principe c'est-à-dire que
comme dans le covid comme dans le covid
elle s'est emparée de la compétence
sanitaire comme pour l'Ukraine elle
essaie de s'emparer de la compétence
militaire
ah elle essaye de s'emparer de la
compétence migratoire bien sûr qu'il
doit y avoir une réponse
européenne
vos alliés italiens qui sont au pouvoir
actuellement la Ligue qui est dans le
même groupe que vous effectivement
Georgie à Meloni ils sont absolument
pour ils disent que ça va les soulager
le bâtiment la technique pour faire
approuver ce type de rapport absolument
catastrophique pour pour le continent
européen c'est d'acheter les pays de
première ligne alors l'Espagne
évidemment qui vont arriver des migrants
la Grèce ou l'Italie ont intérêt à
répartir les migrants dans le reste de
l'Europe ça veut dire non mais attendez
ça veut dire simplement non mais
attendez il y a des il y a des
différences géographiques ça veut dire
simplement que une fois que nos pays
seront submergés les vôtres le seront
alors vous êtes vous êtes espagnol moi
j'étais à Madrid il y a pas longtemps il
y a pas d'immigrés à Madrid venait à
prendre de la chapelle vous verrez ce
que c'est que l'immigration et vous
verrez que là
on peut pas construire
sur l'asile immigration qui jusque là on
peut le dire à rarement fonctionné mille
relocalisations de demandeurs d'asile
seulement sur l'année passée l'objectif
c'est c'est une meilleure répartition de
30 000 demandeurs d'asile pourquoi
aujourd'hui ça pourrait marcher
ravironnement et nos Suns
on va encore insister sur le fait de
solidarité parce que 30 000 migrants sur
450 millions de personnes mais même on
les répartit franchement est-ce que nos
sociétés modernes on passe cette
capacité d'absorption donc nous on va on
va on va travailler pour
qu'effectivement il y a eu cette
répartitionnerait aujourd'hui alors que
ça ne fonctionne que très peu les années
précédentes parce que il faut qu'on
insiste qu'on travaille qu'on négocie
avec le conseil depuis le Parlement
européen pour arriver et faire
comprendre aux gens que vous savez
surtout l'extrême droite et la droite
ils utilisent ça comme un bouillon de
culture électorale donc les peurs les
craintes
ils alimentent ça mais quand on voit la
réalité mais c'est rien du tout donc
c'est en fait des questions idéologiques
et bon ils font plus de bruit que nous
il faut peut-être le temps c'est vrai
que peut-être que ça va marcher parce
qu'il y a des chiffres 30000 etc on le
disait peut-être aussi parce que le
texte est passé on le disait sans
l'accord des Polonais des Hongrois mais
il n'y a pas de droit de véto c'est la
majorité qualifiée
4 millions de
4 millions de crayon c'est très très
juste mais pas du tout des arguants et
des Syriens alors donc on leur offre une
solution alternative qui est de financer
alors à hauteur de de 20.000 euros par
personne ou aussi les capacités
d'accueil de ces personnes ça paraît
équilibré finalement il n'y a pas
d'obligation à prendre les migrants non
pourquoi est-ce que tous les migrants de
la terre et tous les réfugiés de la
terre devraient venir en Europe il
devrait y avoir des solidarités
régionales il y a des monarchies
pétrolières qui sont richissimes et qui
pourraient accueillir aussi
je suis en train de Oui Oui 20.000 euros
donc on va devoir payer 20000 euros pour
ne pas accueillir des gens comme ils
sont des millions vouloir venir ça va
coûter extrêmement cher moi je voudrais
revenir par exemple la question
convention internationale et qu'il est
respecté peut-être que c'est logique là
mais si vous voulez dire que il faut des
asilia au pourtour des des pays en crise
c'est pas à tenter aux règles
internationales il y a une crise en
Somalie aujourd'hui et bien nous nous
proposons d'y créer de créer autour de
la Somalie des Asia c'est à dire des
cités d'accueil de réfugiés au lieu de
les faire venir en Europe c'est là une
solution tout à fait humaine et tout à
fait externalisation du tri des réfugiés
mais pourquoi devrions-nous accueillir
des républiques
qu'est-ce que c'est que la notion de
réfugiés quelqu'un est il y a une crise
dans un pays quelqu'un se sent menacé il
s'en va et ce qu'il a vocation à
s'installer définitivement dans le pays
qu'il accueille a priori non on doit
penser parce qu'on est optimiste que la
crise va se résorber et que cette
personne pourra ou devra repartir dans
son pays donc il faut avoir avoir des
solidarités régionales et pas que
l'Europe accueille tous les réfugiés de
la terre et des solidarités également
avec les pays qui sont en première ligne
tels que l'Italie la Grèce et l'Espagne
d'ailleurs à virement Sanchez à l'issue
du texte sorti du Conseil européen il
est clairement énoncé que aucun État ne
sera obligé d'accueillir des
relocalisations donc d'accueillir des
demandeurs d'asile vous allez donc sans
doute recevoir plus d'argent mais pas
forcément être soulagé
pour cette cause au sein de la gauche
européenne c'est le soleil vérité soit
obligatoire on a compris que ça allait
être très compliqué vous allez vous
battre pour ça au Parlement
on s'est rendu compte que c'est très
compliqué donc on essaie d'aller le plus
loin possible mais ce que je voudrais
dire à Monsieur Olivier est-ce qu'un
jour est-ce que moi je suis fils
d'immigré est-ce qu'un jour vous avez
pensé que vous auriez pu naître à Kaboul
et être une femme
qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là est-ce
que ces gens n'ont pas le droit à
essayer d'avoir une vie meilleure
proposée une solution alternative qui
n'est pas une
propositions
ils n'ont pas le droit de venir en
Europe pourquoi parce que je crois aux
solidarité régionale je crois tout à
fait normal d'accueillir des réfugiés
Ukrainiens en Europe je crois moins
normal d'accueillir toute la Somalie en
Europe je pense que des pays limitrophes
sont tout à fait capables de le faire
ils ne sont pas moins ils ne sont pas
méprisés avec votre théorie les
États-Unis seraient vides et le Canada
aussi oui mais vous êtes vous êtes pour
une vision nomade moi je suis une pauvre
pour moi
c'est vous qui êtes dans un autre monde
parlons de cette attaque au couteau à
Annecy par Abdel Sami Hanoun ainsi rien
qui avait obtenu un statut de réfugiés
en Suède et attendu huit mois une
réponse à sa demande d'asile en France
ce qui soulève d'ailleurs la question
des délais de traitement des dossiers de
la coopération entre État membre
peut-être aussi du suivi de ces migrants
qui qui vont mal euh psychologiquement
est-ce qu'il y a une marge
d'amélioration justement on parle on
parle de de délai raccourcis est-ce
qu'il y a une marge d'amélioration dans
ce dans ce système et je crois que avec
ces délais raccourcis on nous balade la
vérité mais madame Johansson qui est
commissaire européen l'a dit et vous le
dites aussi il faut accueillir la terre
entière en Europe on nous dit Madame
nous dit l'Europe vieilli il faut
maintenant accueillir très largement y
compris des gens non qualifiés des gens
qualifiés en Europe pour repeupler
l'Europe c'est d'ailleurs la vision que
que des formations
balade les gens avec des faux débats le
vrai débat c'est une conception
idéologique qui veut faire de l'Europe
un hall de gare alors que nous nous
avons une vision enracinée de défense
des nations et vous avez cité à juste
titre la Pologne et la Hongrie qui
défendent leur pays et leur peuple 90%
de la migration en Afrique c'est sur le
continent africain 80 au moins
90 alors 10% de migration d'Afrique
suffit à repeupler pratiquement toute
l'Europe
illégales l'année dernière sur toute
l'Europe oui par la voix méditerranéenne
et au total
voilà 330 000 selon France
peut-être parce que la réforme sur la
table veut mettre en place une procédure
d'examen accélérée si on en parlait sans
ces durer en moyenne 12 semaines pour se
considérer comme pouvant présenter une
menace pour la sécurité ou ayant
statistiquement peu de chance de voir
leur demande d'asile accepter en
fonction de leur pays d'origine on parle
peut-être de pays comme la Tunisie le
Maroc le Pakistan c'est peut-être une
bonne chose mais déjà on a bien du mal
ensuite à les renvoyer vers leur pays
d'origine
on peut pas les renvoyer donc c'est le
principe de non refoulement donc ça
aussi c'est un leurre de penser que
faisant ça s'il y a pas c'est pour ça
que il faut une politique holistique et
un des éléments clés un des éléments
clés c'est travailler avec les pays
d'origine et de transit de ces de ces
migrants on a bien du mal à obtenir des
décès consulaires avec les filles avec
l'Algérie avec le Maroc avec le Maroc
l'Algérie la Mauritanie et le Sénégal et
ça a marché ça a marché parce que
c'était une approche holistique on a
développé des projets en commun on leur
a expliqué que ça servait à rien de
traverser les maires parce qu'il risque
de mourir et tout et on a réussi à à
complètement freiner mais en coopération
directe avec les États membres
d'ailleurs
en Tunisie pour pour signer cette grande
accord finalement proposé un milliard
d'euros à long terme avec la nécessité
pour la Tunisie avec Georget Meloni
d'ailleurs de reprendre ses
ressortissants et de les délivrer les
laisser passer consulaires en retour
comprendre parce qu'elle est submergée
elle-même le poids de l’immigration mais
moi je voudrais dire une chose c'est que
essayer de d'attendre des accords comme
on attend la pluie dans le désert est-il
absolument oui et comme ça et à ce time
il y a on a vu la situation quand le
Maroc avait décidé d'ouvrir les vannes
en réalité qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut
faire pression sur les pays or le pacte
l'immigration prévoit prévoit de ne pas
faire pression et bien il y a des
transferts financiers il y a des aides
que l'on peut accorder ou qu'on peut ne
pas accorder il y a des lignes il y a
des visas qu'on ne peut ne plus donner y
compris à des dirigeants africains il y
a des choses que l'on peut faire mais
qu'on ne veut pas faire pourquoi parce
que comme je vous l'ai dit l'immigration
n'est pas un problème pour vous monsieur
vous avez un problème c'est un projet de
submersion du continent et de la nation
ça sera jamais un problème parce que
vous êtes en train de dire
vous êtes en train de dire que je suis
un problème et non pas un problème
vous êtes en train de
pour conclure cette ce débat vous voyez
très euh très fondamental juste est-ce
que ce texte a des chances d'être adopté
selon vous avant les élections de juin
c'est le but
et la présidente espagnole va c'est
s'engage un travailleur maximum après
c'est quand même
à partir de juillet
c'est quand même plusieurs directives et
vous savez les négociations les
trilogues sont assez toujours assez
complètes attendez
de rendre ce texte applicable
électoral pour les élections 2024 merci
en tout cas à tous les deux d'avoir été
justement dans ce débat qui est très
virulent en Europe et vous restez sur
nos antennes pour la suite des
programmes
[Musique]